Speaking of blood fucking let's talk about you sorta yeah.
Without the loop.
Yeah.
We were,
um,
we,
we started this podcast.
I'm talking about what we talked about your,
your situation with Brendan Schaub and I had talked about your situation where
you a war,
you tested positive from a tainted supplement,
like legitimately tested positive from a tainted supplement.
You were cleared,
but this whole process was a goat rope.
Yeah.
Right.
It took a long time to work out and you didn't feel like you were fairly
treated.
Yeah.
Not In the least.
It,
it,
uh,
it started one way,
then took a fucking curve.
What happened?
Well,
so did you take a,
I took a supplement that had tribulus in it.
That's all.
It was just a Chinese herb.
It's a Chinese herb that stimulates testosterone and by the way,
barely work.
Yeah.
It's not,
it's not a,
it's not going to turn you into superman or anything.
Like if you get more sleep,
it's better for your testosterone production than Tribulus.
So it's just tribulus is all it was.
And,
uh,
they in it,
the,
the supplement itself as it turns out,
was contaminated with a sarms called [inaudible].
But when I say contaminated,
I mean like it had such trace amounts that the people that did the lab testing
on it said,
well,
it's clearly just contamination because this wouldn't help you.
This wouldn't do anything for you.
And those,
let's explain how that happens.
A lot of these places,
I know this for a fact because I am one of the owners of on it on it is a third
party tested company where we get our stuff tested by an independent party to
make sure that there's nothing funky with it.
But we've had some issues in the past with stuff being in our,
with our earliest formulations of Alpha brain and weren't supposed to be in
there.
And what it comes from is you buy your ingredients from a company.
The company has these vats that they mix everything in and they don't properly
clean the vats.
And if they don't properly clean the VAT,
so you're buying some stuff from China who knows what they're chucking in there.
They got steroids in there.
They got this,
they got that.
A lot of creatine is tainted,
were all sorts of shit,
a lot of different supplements or tanked.
And that's what you saw it.
I thought it could have been at first.
Tim Means yes,
it happens to um,
uh,
Yoel Romero.
Yes.
Lots of goals.
So this stuff is,
is,
is contaminated.
Right.
And so you saw it was,
was testing me.
I had had a fight in September of 2016 against our Lawsky and then after that I
was like,
Yo,
I'm just going to take a break for a while.
I'm not fighting for,
I'm going to tour Europe and goof off and whatever.
And then when I get back,
I,
you know,
I don't really,
I dunno what I'm going to get back in the ring.
And they're like,
all right,
whatever.
And Ufc we told them and,
but you saw it would still come around and test and it's like,
okay,
fine,
whatever.
So this is post testing positive.
This is pre.
Pre.
Okay.
And so you fought Arlovski and you said,
I'm just going to chill for a while.
Yeah.
And then one day,
uh,
well like for one,
when I'm out there in Europe and I let them know like,
Hey,
I'm going fucking where the wind takes me in Europe and I don't have a
whereabouts to fill in because I could be on a train moving here,
moving there,
whatever,
which is your prerogative,
right as a human being.
And they,
they know that and yet then they go ahead and sent someone to my fucking house
to try and test me while I'm in Europe and I'm just going,
Whoa,
okay.
Isn't there like an app or you feel as an APP?
But if I'm at work,
you have,
you can fill out what you're supposed to be ahead of time for the most part.
So on Tuesday the 16th,
I'm going to be at this place from this time to this time and then,
and then,
but what is your home base?
So if we don't go to these places and we'll just meet you at your home at some
time or whatever,
he just decided to go to Japan.
Yeah.
Do you have to tell them,
hey,
today I'm going to take a train to Osaka today I'm going to go to the mountains.
So you have to give them a detailed itinerary every day.
Every day.
Okay.
And so I'm like,
Fuck Dude,
I'm just trying to be out here living just doing whatever.
I'm not fighting,
but you know,
when I get home,
you test me wherever you want.
You just want him to enjoy a vacation,
just travel.
Correct.
And uh,
they go,
they send someone in my house.
I was like,
fuck.
All right.
And then there are times where,
so what happens when they send someone to your house,
but you told them you weren't there?
Uh,
well for one,
no one told them.
I don't know how,
what mechanical elements within their organization,
how that works.
But they sent someone there anyways.
I'm not there.
That can use a head count.
Does it count because you,
did you tell them that you were going to be on the road?
I,
we did.
So they still counted that as you not being there for a test?
Yes.
Well that doesn't make any fucking sense.
Well,
it is what it is.
So,
uh,
but wait a minute,
if they're going to give you a strike,
like don't,
don't,
they have to follow their protocol and their protocols.
You have to inform them of where you're going to be.
Right.
Because you did that.
You inform them.
Where are you going to be?
My manager literally told new whiskey and the UFC,
he's not going to be home for almost a month and he's fucking practically
backpacking all through Europe going from place to place to place.
So he's going to be real hard to get ahold of.
Good time to take steroids.
Oh yeah.
Get just,
just,
just fucking get that.
Come back
to the gills.
Yeah.
You'll pass.
If they showed up in Europe,
you did give them your location and you told them where you are if they would,
but I was gone.
I didn't fill in any locations.
I just went wherever I went.
So when you went,
wherever you went and your manager told you,
saw that you were in Europe,
they still showed up your house in La.
Okay,
well that doesn't seem to make any sense.
And,
and they give you a strike.
Yes.
So I'm like,
okay,
that's aggravating.
I don't cowboy is strike when he was at UFC.
Yeah.
So it's stuff like that and I saw that and I'm like,
you know what,
I just,
I,
I can't fuck around with any of this stuff.
I don't want people to use this as some sort of a kindling to try and start a
fire about me.
And so then I get back home and they're,
you know,
test me again,
like all right,
fine,
whatever.
And then they test me again and I'm like,
okay,
now you made,
just made me late to an audition as you just showed up out of nowhere.
Cool.
I can do that.
Like they can just show up.
You can't say,
Hey,
I have an appointment to keep their there.
We even if you're not fighting,
like say if you're running out the door and you have a business appointment,
how long does it take for them to test you?
A depends on what they're doing,
whether it's blood and urine or just urine.
Both me,
it's always been blood in urine.
So you can't say,
hey,
you guys are going to have to come with me because uh,
I got to go to this fucking audition,
you know,
I dunno,
I didn't try that.
I would say that get in the car bitch,
boom.
Well how are you going to sit there and have someone draw blood and not going to
you?
You guys are going to have to deal when I'm done.
Like if you want to keep an eye on me,
come with me the whole way.
I always took it as they showed up.
It's like,
well here it goes.
That doesn't seem to make any sense.
If you have previous commitments and you have to do something,
they shouldn't have like ultimate precedent over your life.
Like they shouldn't be able to just decide like showing up randomly.
I San Jose could,
they could make an argument in some way on that.
But if you have a life,
well in any case,
so I take this test and I'm like,
all right,
I'm just going to retire for now.
I got too much shit I got to do.
I'm not fighting anytime soon.
I've got my new Japan and stuff,
I've got auditions,
I've got all these things.
I'm traveling and I just,
I'm not going to fight.
Right.
So just leave me be,
and then I'm in Japan and the fucking,
the very last test I took right before retiring.
Oh,
your flag.
And I'm like,
you gotta be fucking kidding me.
Really,
really.
All these tests over all these years,
me being the first person to do complete out of competition or are in
competition,
random urine and blood testing.
When I worked with a water and then Nevada state athletic commission when I
fought Travis Browne.
So no one had ever done actual random testing before and there was no,
you saw to involve in the UFC yet going through,
why did you do that?
It was something that the NSAC wanted to see done and I'm like,
fine.
You know what?
I wanted to see that done because you had tested positive in the past.
And so I was like,
do you tested positive before in the past you've taken some stuff,
right?
I tested positive for antibiotics in the past while,
but I mean the supplement market used to be way wilder than it used to be.
Well and also well end the way.
The just fighting was way wild riding was way while they're,
the supplement industry was way wilder.
It's like back in Oh two you could still buy all this shit over the counter.
That bio for got reclassified as steroids.
I remember I was taking this shit called Mag 10 I remember 10 what was the name
of the company that makes that a death incorporate ethic cooperated that she I
should is all steroids is steroids.
It was steroids.
100%.
I remember [inaudible] he came like 10 pounds in six weeks on that shit.
You just get Jack.
But that was all over the counter.
Yeah.
You used to be able to buy a lot of stuff.
And by the way,
liver toxicity is probably off the charts.
Probably.
It was a lot of those things that are like super bad for you.
Yeah.
But real effective,
they fucking work.
This stuff worked.
But,
uh,
so,
you know,
there was a whole different era.
And then with California,
you know,
I,
I had an issue with,
with a contaminant,
what I believe ultimately to be a contamination,
but I didn't take all the steps that I had this time.
And once that whole process was such a motherfuck,
I'm like,
this is never going to happen again.
So every supplement lot that I took,
I would always keep bits of it behind for,
until I need,
I could,
I felt there was enough time it expired and get rid of it because no one's going
to come back and test me.
I passed all my tests.
So,
so once you pass your test,
you would get rid of the old site.
I don't need to keep those lots.
And you're supposed to take the only third party verified.
That's not what they say necessarily.
They suggested,
I guess now,
but I know that,
uh,
with this brand of Tribulus I'd taken,
I had taken three or four different other supplements in the same company and
all pass no problem on their test.
Right.
So it was just some weird contamination,
which does happen again.
Happened at Tim means,
yes,
it's happened to several funny as far as I can tell.
I mean,
I'm not testing their whole product line,
but it just seemed like a fluke and just such a simple supplement in any case
over one ingredient deal.
So then they come back,
they're like,
oh,
you tested positive for this.
I'm like,
well,
that ain't fucking possible.
So then I send in some supplements,
which I had to pay for to have them tested.
They run him through the testing and then bang,
they find it all right.
There you go.
There's your deal.
Then they went out and bought a brand new bottle,
unopened.
Same Lot tested that one.
Verify the results.
Same thing.
Test,
same thing.
Doesn't happen.
Then Tim means as well.
So then you were in contact with Usada throughout the entirety of this.
So we don't ever break contact with Usada.
Uh,
we have a specific guy,
and I'm not going to throw his name out there or anything,
but we have a guy that we spoke to directly the whole time through my manager.
Uh,
speaking with him and I've seen the emails and so we're talking about how we
know this is a contamination.
And when,
you know,
when we get done with all this,
why don't we even try to put together something,
some,
some promotional stuff,
anything that we can do to try and keep athletes from ending up in the same
issues.
And we,
we'd like to do whatever we could to help you guys out with this.
You know,
we're not against you.
We're up.
We don't mind being a part of the system and we understand why you're here.
And I'm not against them wanting to do drug testing or whatever and try to keep
a,
a clean and fair playing field.
I,
I get the point of it.
Uh,
so we get the supplements tested,
they test the secondary batch,
they have all their information.
It's like,
all right,
this would be a fucking rock and roll.
And then they got real quiet.
Okay.
Uh,
now you're not talking to us anymore.
What do you mean?
Like you would contact them,
they wouldn't respond.
They would take him a week,
two weeks.
And what were they saying when they do respond?
Uh,
you know,
I,
I can't entirely remember myself if my manager was in touch with them.
And what is the protocol?
If someone tests positive for something that's a tainted Sapa men and it's a
third party supplement and where it's not or it was not third party verified
rather well,
I don't even know if it was third party verified that anything would be any
different.
Hmm,
okay.
Well if it is third party verified and still is tainted,
yeah,
that would be an issue,
right?
Yeah.
If you tested positive,
he tested positive,
they found a supplement.
I think the idea about third party verified is it's much less likely to be a
taste.
It does include solve anything.
Right.
And this is coming from someone who's in the supplement business,
you know,
there's a certain amount of this stuff you farm out.
So,
uh,
as far as I know what the deal is,
there is a period of ineligibility sort of,
or basically what,
what happens is you're effectively suspended until this thing is all finished
out and they tried to say that you're not suspended.
There's no suspension,
but that's not true.
But no one's going to book you for a treat you as you're suspended.
I tried to Corner Travis Brown cause I was training him and they wouldn't let
me,
it wouldn't let you the corner mission with let me try it.
Yes.
Okay.
And so a lot.
And they're like,
you're suspended so you can't,
you can't corner.
But you said you're not suspended.
Yeah,
exactly.
Okay.
So you're effectively suspended.
You can't work.
You can't even work as a tertiary individual,
as a,
as a corner man or anything like that.
He can't be at the event.
And this is after the fact where you brought them,
the supplements,
they independently verified that it was tainted.
And uh,
so then we start talking and,
and throughout the process I said,
look,
I'm not taking a punishment for contamination and I'm not even fighting.
I'm not fighting anytime soon.
I'm not you.
You can't like what you did with means and these other people,
you punish them.
You know that there was contamination,
but you punish them.
Yeah.
They gave them many months.
Yes.
Of A,
you know,
suspension.
So that they weren't able to compete or make a living during those months.
And I'm like,
no,
I'm not dealing.
I'm not taking that.
That's not acceptable because I'm not,
that's not what's going on here.
Nobody is doping.
Nobody's trying to cheat the system.
There is no,
I'm not even fighting you.
You don't get by punishing me.
You're trying to live guilt on me.
You're trying to make me out to be some sort of,
uh,
you know,
guilty party as if I'm trying to be achieved of some sort.
And I was like,
I'm not dealing,
I'm not taking that.
So how did it ultimately get resolved?
Well,
ultimately what ended up happening is we had to go to arbitration.
That was all,
it was really left to us because then they started trying to bring up,
uh,
stuff from my past and then weigh that against me as well.
And it's like,
Whoa,
dude,
you guys weren't even around.
And now you get to decide to add to the weight of,
of whatever punishments you want to levy against me based on things that didn't
involve you.
Great.
What were they talking about?
They're talking about 2001 no,
2008 they went to 2008 yeah,
they tried and they tried to say,
well,
oh yeah,
well this happened.
So then therefore,
you know,
now they start talking about two years.
[inaudible] thank you.
And you gotta be fucking kidding me.
They start talking about suspending you for two years for a tainted supplement.
Yes.
Wow.
And I'm just going,
there's no way.
I wouldn't even expect six months.
You think I'm going to take two years.
And so we go and we inquire on the Arbor and I've done,
I did an interview with the guy that we were dealing with through Skype.
Uh,
we've,
we've been in touch.
It's just like at some point,
everything turned and changed.
Their tone changed there.
Even the original penalties,
they were looking to levy increased.
New Shit gets brought in.
It's like they became a completely different animal.
As soon as you know,
there was the evidence of contamination and that I wasn't gonna I wasn't willing
to take punishment for it.
It wasn't.
What do you think their motivation is here?
I don't think that they,
and this is just my opinion,
I think the way you saw to looks at it,
and it's an easy way to go about it,
is that the more people they deem,
the more effective they appear.
It's their affect.
Their efficacy is based on Punnett,
on punishments,
doled out,
not necessarily,
not on lack of punishments at all.
So do you think this is,
you know,
also remembered by the people that are working there so they arbitrarily get to
decide how things go about right.
There's not like a very strict protocol that they must follow.
They're tainted supplements are for this?
No,
there is actually quite a bit of a lever or there's,
there's leeway in terms of how they can enforce them,
what they can enforce.
So when,
so subjective it's up,
there is subjectivity in it.
Um,
they uh,
they have a lot of discretion.
There is some outlined elements of protocol,
but there is no,
it is always this or it is always that.
And,
uh,
you know,
I didn't begrudge them for a period of ineligibility while you're going through
the process of finding out whether this is contamination or what have you doing
any testing.
And that makes sense to me.
That's fine.
I understand that if this guy supposedly has something in a system,
well let's figure out what it is and once we have a better idea,
then we can decide about whether you can go back into the pool or do this or do
that or with,
if you're going to ever any punishments make sense to me.
But in addition to that,
then tacking on more shit in terms of my case and I was like,
that's not acceptable.
So we,
we go,
well I guess the only thing left to us as to go to arbitration.
And so my manager spoke with,
um,
when I was working through them to arbitration and we said,
okay,
well we'll,
what is that going to take?
Well,
that's going to cost more money out of my pocket.
Um,
you know,
the arbitration process,
these are guys that they're paid by Usada to do their arbitration.
Like they worked for them in a way or they're not,
they don't work under them directly,
but they are,
they do get paid to be a arbitrary to somehow there's some something get
contracted by Usada.
Yes.
And uh,
and so that was like,
ah,
I don't necessarily feel the most comfortable with that,
but I don't,
I can also understand how it's not,
there's probably not an easier way to go about it,
but,
okay.
I got it.
Then when we,
uh,
then we get notice back from Usada that we have to limit the scope of our
argument.
We're like,
Whoa,
what you,
you're going to tell us what we can and can't argue.
And arbitration,
I don't remember what the definitions were exactly,
but it was like,
you can't,
you know,
you have to keep it within this boundary and this realm and this.
And I'm like,
well,
you can't fucking try to say the levy this against me and then you stuff from my
past and then tell me I can't argue my full case.
So they're limiting the amount that you could defend yourself as though you're
saying basically like they were limiting the,
um,
the range of argument.
You could make the argument be that you would bring up,
that they would want to limit?
Uh,
that's a good question.
I don't know exactly.
Did they define that?
They know they had definitions in the emails with,
with back and forth with my manager.
And he goes,
well fuck we,
you know,
cause we could argue about,
um,
you know,
this is contamination.
Um,
and,
and go from there.
But if it's something really potentially limiting,
which was weird about how they put it,
I just don't remember what exactly,
I don't remember all the details.
It's very detail oriented.
It's legal ease.
And uh,
and then so we get to the point,
it's like,
well fuck,
well this doesn't even look like a very,
you know,
this might not even be a,
a useful way of trying to approach this thing.
And it got down to the wire to where,
and we kept pushing it back and pushing it back and saying like,
you know,
we can we get an extension and,
and to try and figure out how the hell did we approach this.
And,
and also like how,
how could we approach it without having to spend money on having lawyers get
involved.
I mean that's the last thing you want to do is get to litigation or you know,
even arbitration.
It's a legal process.
It's complex and it is,
it's,
there's a lot of uh,
and lawyers love billable hours or they do and so it gets down to the wire
essentially.
And we,
I just sit back and I go,
I won't accept any ruling if it's a punishment at all.
I don't care what they say.
I'll just be like,
Nah,
not I,
I don't,
I'm not going to abide by it.
You can't force me to do shit.
And I guess we'll have to cross
position is that if you are accidentally taking a tainted supplement and also
trace amounts that have absolutely zero effect on performance,
there's nothing that you're doing by accidentally taking that that in any way
would help you and that's a fact.
That's a proven fact.
Yes.
So your position is you shouldn't be punished.
Correct.
Then you're out of the year when,
once you,
the time that you've been out.
Here's the thing,
that's enough.
Exactly.
It's one thing you don't need to say,
oh well if you,
if it took six,
if it took a seven months to get the,
the,
the information that you needed the data,
right to then clarify,
okay,
well you're not at fault to then say,
oh well we'll suspend you for six months.
But since that six months is already past,
it's like we didn't suspend you at all.
No.
Motherfucker,
when you look in the end of the hunt at the data,
when you go and look at this case,
it says suspended,
which means you punished me,
which means I was guilty in some way.
You said I'm guilty because that's how you got to punish me,
right.
It's not,
it's under investigation or you know,
after investing you're exonerated after invest.
No,
it's just,
no,
you still love to punishment in there to say,
look how we caught this guy and we punished him and I'm like,
I'm not,
I'm not gonna,
I'm not down for that.
And so oddly enough,
so I was like on aerials or something like that and I said,
I,
I won't accept,
I don't care what they say.
I don't care what punishment they tried to levy.
I don't abide by it.
I won't agree to it.
And I'm done with them.
I,
and someone from the arbitrary,
the arbitrators office who we were dealing with calls us out of the blue and
goes,
so he,
so you still sure you don't want to do this?
I'm like,
well,
and my manager goes,
they said that we have to limit the scope of argument to this and this and we
can't talk.
And then he goes,
no,
you don't.
You can talk about,
you can,
you can bring any argument you want.
Who is saying this to you?
The arbitrator's office,
this,
so who would initially come to you and said the elite,
the scope,
your argument.
Usada okay,
so you saw it.
It was attempting to establish some boundaries for your arguments.
But the people who are the actual arbitrators said that that's not true.
Right?
They,
that's not the case.
You don't have,
it doesn't,
they can't force you to argue in a certain,
oh,
okay.
So is it possible that you sought as lawyers?
We're trying to,
here's the thing I've found about,
about lawyers,
like yeah,
for sure they're necessary and that's all well and good and you need them.
But there's a reality,
and this is something that I had to deal with recently in doing something with a
friend through lawyers where they attached to a bunch of shit to this deal that
wasn't supposed to be in there and he didn't even know it was in there.
And then my lawyer is like,
what the fuck is this?
And so I contact him,
And he's like,
what the fuck is that?
So he contacts his lawyers.
What the fuck is this?
And it turns out this is a common thing.
Lawyers,
they wanted to do with each other.
Yeah.
We put this in to give you leverage.
I don't think you necessarily want that,
but we're looking out for your best interests.
And so now you have a good negotiation point.
If you just go in with what you want,
then they're going to ask for more than that.
And then you're not in a strong position because you can't ask for more after
you've already established your initial position.
Everything convoluted there grows by.
But that's the world we live in.
Grandfather was a Tejas world,
pretty,
pretty fair lawyer was assistant attorney
general,
the state of Washington.
He actually wanted me to get into law of all things,
but I'm like,
Eh,
I think are the beat out.
My brain's yet seems like,
well,
you haven't beaten them out.
Very impressive with your memory.
So we,
uh,
we get to,
my manager comes back to me.
He goes,
hey man,
they just contacted me out of nowhere.
And they're like,
well,
if you want to do this,
you can,
and no,
you can't,
you,
you can make the argument,
there's no limiting in the scope of your argument or anything.
So then it's like,
well yeah,
all right,
I'll go for it.
Cause we went to our least.
Yeah.
Cause at the very least I thought maybe I could have some sort of record down
of,
of what,
what we talked about,
what was discussed,
the arguments made.
So in the end,
you know,
no matter how it came out,
I can go here,
here's what's legit and then you can,
you can make your own decision from there.
And so we go in,
uh,
I brought my legal team.
They,
he,
they had a,
their lawyer come who was the same guy we were dealing with throughout the
entire process.
And they made,
you know,
their argument and we made ours and you know,
and there,
there are times where I'm sitting back and I go,
you know,
making,
they're making closing arguments,
each lawyers,
and I'm just sitting there listening to the Usada Seigel oh man.
He's just pushing them and he's just moving the goalposts.
He's,
uh,
how so?
Well,
it's just taking a certain element and then trying to use slippery slope
arguments and moving the goalposts on things.
But he's just doing anything he can to use rhetoric instead of logos at this
point because,
you know,
they're lawyers and they're trying to make their case and trying to find
impassioned responses when you're saying this,
you know,
consider the people listening at home don't really know your case,
don't know the scope.
So it's like trying to say that,
uh,
you know,
find ways at which to move the goalposts in terms of,
so what,
like I said to you earlier,
I keep batches of all the supplements that I take,
especially when I'm in these,
this program.
And especially after dealing with the cluster fuck that was California.
And it's like,
well,
I didn't have anything that I could bring to you that I could fuck,
you know,
so I'm like,
this is never happening again.
So I keep everything.
They go and they test stuff and they find it and I kept notes.
I kept this.
And it's like,
how,
what more could I have done for you guys?
Even if it doesn't matter if there's,
let's say where they were all third party tested as well.
I would still keep batches of the supplements in any of this stuff.
I take third party testing.
What was the issue then?
Well,
it's just simply it's this,
they kept trying to say that I didn't do a good enough job that uh,
did you use the,
uh,
did you see this thing on supplement form one one?
It's like that came out after the fact and yes I have seen that.
In fact,
I use all the resources that you provided your global dro,
your other supplement,
four one,
one two check against ingredient lists,
supplement names,
company names to make sure none of this shit is on the list so that I don't make
that mistake.
So I use the resources that you give me.
I keep batches of my,
my supplement so they can be tested if be I do what's available to keep from any
issues.
And yet they just kept moving the goalpost on that and trying to say that.
Well,
but you didn't,
uh,
you didn't hire a psychic.
You know,
it's just that kind of shit.
I'm like,
well,
how,
how can this have been any better?
And not to mention I'm not fighting.
Right.
So at the end of the day,
what were they looking for in arbitration?
Uh,
they wanted to levy a punishment against me and suspend me for years.
And this is,
you saw.
Yes.
So you saw it ultimately,
even though they knew that you took a tainted supplement that had no effect
whatsoever on your performance,
right?
They still wanted to punish you for two years.
That seems stupid.
That just seems stupid.
Now,
let me,
let me read Jeff Novitsky because Novitsky texted me because I told them this
was going to go down and his take is a little bit different than yours.
I don't imagine.
It isn't.
All right.
I'm,
I'm not surprised that it is.
And I,
uh,
I told you what it was,
um,
the,
so this is,
I'll just read you what it says.
Uh,
he said he'll complain about the amount of time that went by with Usada process,
but he notified us of retirement right after the positive sample was collected
before,
uh,
positive was announced.
So he was off in the wind for many months and not communicating with you sought
out a big reason.
The case took so long to resolve to his positive was from a tainted supplement,
but he didn't do the number one thing.
We advise the UFC athletes on UFC athletes on supplements.
He didn't choose a supplement that was third party certified,
uh,
as a banned substance free like on its supplements are,
there are literally hundreds of certified supplements out there in virtually and
virtually ensures no issues,
uh,
for an athlete if they stick with those.
Uh,
one other point for Barnett,
when he was unresponsive to case he missed all of his deadlines to file for
arbitration.
Uh,
he came to the table later and said he wanted to go to arbitration.
You saw to made an exclusion and let him,
which ultimately led to his favorable ruling by arbitrator.
Their reasoning was that they wanted to rule in favor of fairness to athlete
rules.
Say they didn't have to after time,
uh,
to file expired.
Well,
but they're saying you it ruled favorably towards you
Melanie at the end of the day.
Yes.
They like gobbly Goop,
this,
that,
the other.
It's just like he says that uh,
oh well he retired and he was in the wind.
You know what my in the wind was?
It wasn't even that long.
I was in Japan for rising with my athlete.
Alyssa Garcia wasn't in the fucking wind.
Sounds good though.
The wind and the wind.
What fucking dude you and that motorcycle jacket just drives him.
Yeah,
I'm a car from behind me,
like Django through the Nevada
desert.
Somebody pulls you over and got eight days growth on your face.
You charge Barnett some days.
Where you Sada we're,
we're looking for bro Broken.
I,
he pissed this cup for me.
Breakup.
Just,
yeah,
I was in Japan at,
you know,
I wasn't in the wind and uh,
they,
so it takes in your favor.
They arbitrary arbitrator and what did they say?
This is the same guy that the arbitrator is,
the same guy that put together is he's an ICARUS.
He produced ICARUS,
the movie on,
on doping.
He is,
he's one of the major figures in terms of the world of anti-doping.
So it's one of the guys who worked with Bryan Fogel.
Uh,
the arbitrator,
it's Bryan Fogel was the guys who started in Icarus.
This guy is a arbitrator for water.
Okay.
Actually why am I doing this?
Either way,
Jamie,
Jamie can handle this,
but it doesn't matter.
Uh,
and so this guy has day everything in terms of,
of drug testing the rule in your favor.
Yes.
And he said he does it.
He couldn't see any way that I could have done hardly a better job than I would
meticulous with my record keeping that uh,
I may,
I did essentially anything I could in the means of a normal person to do.
How was it resolved at the end?
Uh,
it was a,
the last of reprimand.
That's it.
Reprimand?
Yeah.
What does that,
what do they do?
Richard Eight.
Chef Richard Mclaren Claren.
Oh,
see,
chief arbitrator.
Yes.
Okay.
So at the end of the day,
after all this,
they say they give you a reprimand.
What does that mean?
That just means like don't do that.
Be careful.
Yeah.
Okay.
But this took no punishment.
Right?
And so all that two year shit from Usada was unwarranted.
And heavy handed,
heavy handed as hell.
And,
and junior dos Santos went through that too.
Right?
Started at at six months.
And then by the time we,
they have both supplements tested,
then all of a sudden it starts getting weird.
And you know,
this claim by new whiskey that we were out of,
no,
we were always in touch.
Novitsky doesn't work for you saw it.
And I know,
and this is so what's Kinda funny is new whiskey is such a public face on this
kind of thing.
But when it comes to actually dealing with Usada,
he's all,
he's hands up.
I mean,
he'll come and he'll,
he'll make sure to put something out there in any of the sphere.
But in reality,
he ain't got a fucking thing to do with any of them.
Okay.
But in his defense,
he's a UFC employee and it's inappropriate for him to have any influence
whatsoever on the way they rule things that,
but that's,
that is that is that,
I think that's actually the proper thing for him to do it in a way.
But I mean it's just,
it's a,
it's it,
the presentation is a bit of a misnomer.
I think so.
Well initially he was responsible for the drug testing.
Now he's,
what is he,
the president of athletes?
Safety and wellness.
Fuck a flower thing.
They're running the performance institute.
Yeah.
I mean what they're,
what they're concentrating on now I'm just saying it for Jeff and his draft that
I think they're concentrating more on encouraging fighters to train and,
and,
and fortify their body with nutrition correctly and giving them education on how
to do this and that Jeff is at the forefront of that stuff and showing them
how to avoid accidentally taking something and definitely had a little boy where
I'm coming with this is that he is not fully in the loop with what happened
between me and Usada cause he's not involved.
Right.
So some of some of what he's saying there is incorrect and it's not,
I don't blame him because he's not a part of it.
So is he misinformed?
I at the very least,
I think that they,
they're not being straight with it.
It sounds to me like they wanted to punish you badly.
They wanted to punish me badly.
Yeah.
Two years is a fucking crazy punishment.
And also when,
when people get to remember when I'm Nick Diaz was uh,
was being interviewed by all these people and then there was that mean lady who
works in Nevada [inaudible] commission and she was grilling him and I'm like,
well you were talking about pot here.
You crazy lady.
Like what in the fuck are you doing?
You're acting like you've robbed a bank.
Even not if he's not getting the ring.
Hi.
And then leave him alone.
Exactly.
And I think he probably did a few times,
I think.
I think in the go army fighting,
he might've been high.
It was like,
oh,
I'm bleeding.
Oh my God,
maybe I should choke him right now.
He didn't give a shit fight.
Jon Jones is going through this right now.
I don't know where John Jones stands,
but it's been pretty well established that at the very least what the numbers,
if you look at the numbers when he was tested.
Um,
and you know,
I don't,
I know a lot of people like to say that he's a cheater.
There's,
there's a lot of this going on right now.
Look real clear.
The first test was proven that he took tainted Dick Pills.
Okay,
that's fine.
Well it was actually,
so that got brought up to my attention as part of all this because you know,
you saw fell in that relevant,
the difference between that first one,
let's say,
and I'm not,
I don't know about the second shift with John.
I don't really follow close on this,
but this came across my plate because he had,
he was taking like a liquid Cialis and it was from a company that sells sarms
and peptides and all that.
So it was a company that also sells banned substances.
Right.
And so their argument was that dude,
you're buying or using shit from a place full of illegal shit.
You're not supposed to take.
Definitely a dumb move.
Does it mean God damn prescription for Cialis?
Right?
You don't need to take this funky shit.
I imagine.
Um,
the second one,
what he took had such a minuscule trace amount that he tested negative.
Denny tested positive,
then he tested negative again.
And this is something that's supposed to stay in your system for months.
So this is indicative of someone is not taking something to get into performance
enhancing benefit from it,
but rather someone who had something that was tainted.
And these lab technicians
are smart on this shit.
Like the guy who saw,
um,
the results from the,
the,
the first little batch of supplements we gave him,
he,
he had seen everything and then some under the sun and all different levels and
this guy knew what,
what constituted contamination,
right?
Wasn't he could tell,
Of course they can tell just by the numbers.
Look,
if you'd taking trace amounts of anything,
it's not going to do a damn thing to your body in terms of performance
enhancing.
But it is going to show up in these tests because these tests are incredibly
thorough.
Hey Jamie,
Google,
what's going on with Jon Jones case because particularly after this weekend,
it's very,
very relevant.
You know,
I mean with Brock Lesnar getting in there with DC,
just you becoming the first light heavyweight to consecutively hold the light
heavyweight championship and the heavyweight championship,
you know,
and the spectacular fight by DC.
But Jon Jones is always going to be sure.
I mean there you cannot,
you can go on and on about the extra curricular woes of John Jones.
Sure.
His capabilities as an athlete,
his talent is,
is it's undeniable,
undeniable
look,
whatever the fuck he took Dick Pills,
it's not making them a better fighter.
He didn't knock DCL out because of Dick Pills.
That's crazy.
No,
it has to deal with great skill and beautiful left high kick.
That's what it was.
And he recognize a tendency,
DC knows he has,
you know.
Uh,
but with this whole Usada process,
it just became an it drug on because,
you know,
we said to them,
I'm not going to take a punishment.
And they said,
we won't,
we're not giving you any option on this.
And so that's,
it's like there was this negotiation.
What,
what happens,
what I want,
one of the things that I've talked about when it comes to police officers is
that when you have police officers and you know,
people they're trying to arrest it becomes a game.
And I don't mean a game in terms of his bullshit.
I mean it's a game in terms of one person's trying to win and they're trying to
get people and arrest them.
And this is why people plant guns and plant drugs trying to,
when trying to win.
And that's what killed me was that,
to me,
in my opinion,
you soda was trying to win.
It was more important for them to win than it was for us to have a clean sport.
This comes back to what were talking about earlier when it comes to arguments
and discussions that people oftentimes are not really searching for the truth.
They just want to be,
right.
Yes.
And I've had this argument about bureaucracies in general,
right?
And this goes to,
this isn't just about,
you know,
not you saw it and their bureaucratic elements.
I mean,
they're tight,
like the government.
There are other things.
So you come and you say,
Oh,
you fucked up.
And then the bureaucracy's go,
oh shit,
we didn't fuck up.
And they're going to say we didn't fuck up to the very,
they'll take that to the very longest lever until either a they'll scape goat
someone or be,
they can figure out a way that they didn't.
Because looking,
making a mistake on a bureaucratic level makes it seem like,
okay,
well fuck if we f and here's the thing,
if you saw this as,
oh,
you know,
you're not you,
you didn't,
you're not going to get punished then to means,
and you'll run Merrill go,
uh,
what did I get punished?
Or if they,
if you sat down and say,
Oh,
well,
you know,
that was a miss that that was a mistake.
Well if that was a mistake,
we'll then,
hey,
I got fucked on that mistake.
You got to take care of me.
So no drug testing is bad,
but too much oversight is also bad.
I think that a clean sport is,
is AOK,
and the idea of the random testing and all is fine,
but you can't do it at the expense of the athletes in that were in the
administration of the testing that you're trying to blast them.
Like these three Brazilian guys that just got busted over contamination that
they traced back to a compounding pharmacy.
I don't know,
different things.
This is just recent.
So you got three different guys in the UFC and they were all getting supplements
from a compounding pharmacy and everything was traced back to it.
It almost seems like you shouldn't take any fucking supplements.
Well,
that's the other thing.
It's like you'll do we are we not allowed to take anything,
anything at all?
Nothing.
No on it.
What supplements,
what do they do?
They help your performance.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
Should you take no performance and answers?
She should.
We take nothing.
She just eat food.
I mean,
it's gotta be someone out there.
It's just,
well,
there's food that will enhance your performance too.
Right?
Like kangaroo meat,
the Frank Mir took it takes some bad kangaroo meat.
Oh Man.
That kangaroo meat,
he'd get a good pump on that.
First of all,
ain't nobody giving steroids to kangaroo.
Okay.
Kangaroos are fucking everywhere.
Investigation identify as compounding pharmacies as a source of tainted
supplements behind three positive Santos Alomeda and Antonio and yeah,
uh,
Minotauro and here's the weird thing.
So it comes all the way down to it and then they're there highlight on this is,
and you know,
they've,
oh,
we put give them a suspension that,
but at the time has already lapsed so they won't actually have to serve any
time.
It's like,
but you just fucking suspended them nonetheless.
You didn't have to do that.
So they took seven or eight months or whatever for this get cleared up.
And that's unfortunate.
Jr the tested positive for a diuretic,
is that correct?
That's what it was.
Which core something I'd leave just diarrhetic which is crazy because he's a
fucking heavy one,
not losing any weight.
And g junior's not on the high side of heavyweight.
He's not like a to 65 God.
It's kind of wait to make the upper limit.
Like he's just trying to keep those wrinkles on his face.
Just trying to look good.
Maybe just last ride.
Does diuretics make you look good?
Look,
I don't know.
That may seem show herself.
Just tried to write essentially I just pulls all the,
pulls all the water on bones.
Jones keeping mind.
Life is a journey.
Not a race.
God's will for me to be there.
Blah,
blah,
blah.
I forget,
I'm still the youngest guy in the top five of heavyweight and light everywhere.
Yeah,
he is young.
What does that,
what does unique Miseq,
what does that,
oh,
what was he responding to?
Somebody tweeted that a couple hours ago up to a four year span.
Right now he remains a provisional suspension of wind in the outcome of the
situation with Usada after testing positive for steroids.
Last July following the knockout went over,
call me.
Um,
was it as Deb Roy?
Uh,
man,
I couldn't tell you.
John faces up to four year suspension due to second violation.
UFC is anti-doping poverty policy,
but obviously young side,
every champion,
but
obviously first of all,
when it says second violation,
the first violation was proven to be something tainted.
So it's,
he's not,
when you say violation,
I want,
I want to hear this guy took steroids.
He took steroids because he was trying to get a performance enhancing result
from it.
Suspend that guy.
I don't want to hear,
oh,
he got toothpaste.
It's from China and had fucking something in it that you remember that too,
don't you?
Wasn't that a fucking crazy story about the toothpaste that had some poison in
it or something that they were selling in China?
Yeah.
What was that?
Some wild shit.
What was that.